à
l'aube de grands coups frappés à la
porte chez mes grands-parents mais très
violent on venait nous chercher entre 4
heures et 6 heures du matin
nous dormions encore donc réveillés en
sursaut deux policiers français 1 en
uniforme et l'autre en civil 10 allez
les enfants rachel ghedina qu'avait 8
ans à l'époque à paris ces 16 et 17
juillet 1942 elle est arrêtée avec sa
soeur comme treize mille autres juifs
par la police je vois des femmes sortir
de passes tout avec des petits dans les
bras d'eau qui comme moitié d'un robot
la jupe de la maman et on nous fait
avancer comme un troupeau en troupeau et
toiles et les mamans hurlait mais où
allons-nous où nous emmener vous les
policiers ne répondait pas
j'ai vu des gens massés aux fenêtres
d'autres sur les trottoirs qui nous
regardaient passer certains faisaient le
signe de croix les larmes aux yeux
d'autres nous montrer du doigt en riant
elles sont emmenés à la bellevilloise à
paris cette salle a été réquisitionnée
par le gouvernement de vichy pour en
faire un centre de rétention rachat
jedinak et sa soeur parviennent à
s'échapper ma mère s'est tourné vers
nous et nous a dit je ne vais plus vous
voir trade mois vous allez près de
l'issue de secours et si on vous empêche
de sortir vous trouvé le moyen de sortir
beau rester là bas je n'ai pas voulu
lâcher ma mère j'ai fait une comédie
j'ai hurlé je ne vais pas quitter
alors elle a fait quelque chose que je
ne pouvais pas raconter au début sans
pleurer ma mère m'a giflé violemment la
seule gifle de ma vie c'est plus tard
que j'ai compris que cette gifle m'a
sauvé la vie je suis parti vers l'issue
de secours avec ma soeur est là les deux
policiers en faction
on tournait la tête pour ne pas nous
vous sortir mais d'autres n'ont pas eu
cette chance plus de 8000 juifs sont
emmenés puis parqués dans un stade à
l'ouest de paris le vélodrome d'hiver
cinquante trois ans après la rafle la
france reconnaissait sa responsabilité
dans ce drame oui la folie criminelle de
l'occupant a été chacun le sait
second départ des français
seconde et par l'état la reconnaissance
de jacques chirac au bout de cinquante
ans de la responsabilité de vichy
l'établi sheed la france d'alors
nous a permis enfin de nous exprimer les
vannes se sont ouvertes et nous avons
commencé à parler
[Musique]